did you call all the actors uh not all
but JK you called it you know JK I do we
did a movie 15 years ago and everything
I ever write I'm thinking of him for
something and he's such a he's such a no
non-hollywood guy that like you
know he reads something if he likes it
he'll tell you if he doesn't like it he
doesn't have some agent telling him what
he should or should not do he you know
he if he likes something he does it and
so you called him said look I got the
script I think it's great I said read it
he said I like it if the agents can
figure out how to pay me would I need to
get paid I'll do it and so he want you
know you got to pay a guy like that yeah
of course you know I remember I did a
movie called pool hall junkies which
didn't do well but it was a fun little
movie and they got Chris walking yeah
and you know he got paid a lot he was
most of the budget yeah he only worked
like four days yeah that's right how do
we get that I want to get that